يبدو أن ما يسمى بشرطة الأخلاق في إيران
قد تتعرض للضرب بوحشية من خلال فرض
قواعد اللباس الصارمة في البلاد، ويقول الناشطون إن فتاة تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا
تعرضت للضرب المبرح، ويقال إنها الآن
في غيبوبة في المستشفى لأنها
لم تكن ترتدي الحجاب.  جام
كاديس لديه
تفاصيل تتهم مجموعات ناشطة إيرانية
شرطة الأخلاق
بالاعتداء على فتاة تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا في
محطة مترو طهران لعدم ارتدائها
الحجاب الإلزامي أو غطاء القبعة،
ويقول النشطاء إن أرميتا جارافان
كانت في غيبوبة منذ يوم الأحد وفقًا لـ
المجموعة المعارضة الناشطة إيران سلك
تم إدخالها إلى المستشفى بسبب
صدمة في الرأس، ولم نتمكن بعد من
التحقق بشكل مستقل من هذه المعلومات.
نشرت وسائل الإعلام التابعة للدولة مقطع فيديو لمجموعة
من الفتيات شوهدن يدخلن
قطار المترو ويبدو أن بعض الفتيات اللاتي يدخلن
لا  ترتدي الحجاب في مقطع
الفيديو هذا بعد لحظات، ويظهر
مجموعة من الفتيات يحملن جافون خارج
قطار المترو ويضعنها على الرصيف
قبل مغادرة القطار، ولا
يمكن رؤية أي مشاجرة في هذا الفيديو المعدل الذي
تم نشره على وسائل الإعلام الحكومية.  لم
نتمكن من تأكيد صحتها أيضًا، حيث
أخبر الرئيس التنفيذي لمترو طهران
وسائل الإعلام الحكومية أنه لم يكن هناك أي
تفاعل جسدي أو لفظي بين
موظفيه وغارافند،
ولم تستجب الحكومة الإيرانية بعد
لطلبنا للتعليق وأخبر
والدا غاران  وسائل إعلام حكومية في مقابلة
قيل لهم إن ابنتهم
ضربت رأسها بعد أن أغمي عليها بسبب انخفاض
ضغط الدم بينما كانت في طريقها
إلى المدرسة. يقول الوالدان إنه
لم تكن هناك علامات من مقاطع الفيديو التي رأوا
أنها تعرضت للاعتداء ولكن الأمر كذلك
من المهم أن نشير إلى أننا لا نعرف
الظروف التي أجريت فيها هذه المقابلة
وفي الماضي أخبرتنا الأمم المتحدة وجماعات
حقوق الإنسان أه أن
عائلات المتظاهرين الذين قتلوا خلال
احتجاجات العام الماضي كانوا يتعرضون للضغط
والضغط للإدلاء بتصريحات
داعمة  رواية الحكومة أن
الصحفية التي ذهبت إلى ذلك المستشفى
للإبلاغ عن حالة جاران تم
اعتقالها لفترة وجيزة يوم الثلاثاء وتم
إطلاق سراحها لاحقًا وفقًا
لصحيفتها جامان كاتشي سي إن إن لندن